CAN.
HE IS TRYING TO MATCH UP
AGAINST THE CROSBY REBOUND. COOD
PRESSURE. CARRIER IS
KAPANEN.
MILLER HAS A BREAKAWAY.
SH
>> J.T. TRYING TO PROTECT THAT
PUCK FROM THE BACK CHECK OF
FACEOFF.
>> SHOTS, 9-SBURGH.
THEY ARE FEEDING OFF THE
ENERGY OF THE TEAM.
THE PENGUINS HAVE BEEN VERY
CLOSE
SIDE.
THE PASS WAS TAKEN AWAY.
NOBODY
SEASON, YOU SEE THE PENGUINS TH1
REMAINING IN THE FIRST.
PLENTY OFMKO WITH A BIG STOP.
BRIAN DUMOULIN RIGHT DOWN THE
>> Referee: HOOKING.
>> THERE YOU SEE THE PUCK IS
JUST ON THE BACK SIDE OF CLOSED.
POWER PLAY.!
[AIR HORN]E, QUICKLY, FLAT.
HE RIPS IT.
6'8" DEFENSEMAN.
CONTINUES.
CROSBY, THE BACKHANDE
TRYING TO GO FAR SIDE ON
>> KNOCKED DOWN BY JARRY.
HE GETS TO THE NEAR WALL AND
HE IS DENIED.
THE WRALLENGED HIM.
MILLER, WITH THE ONE SCORES!
ASTON-
THENDRE FLEURY.
HE PUT THE WORK IN.
FIRES OFF THE BAR!
THAT COULD BLUEGER.
STOPPED BY GUENTZEL.
PENALTY KILL.
BLUEGER, LOOK HOW HIS STICK
WAS EXTENDED.
HIS A UP.
WRAP ARO
JARRY.
ANOTHER
IN ONE, ONE OF HIS BEST
GUENTZEL.
>> THAT WAS A QUICK PASS BY STI.
IT LANDS RIGHT ON THE TAPE OF
GUENTZEL.
CHASEN FIRES IT SHUTOUT BID WHEK
GOES OFF THE GOALPOST AND
>> PETTERSSON AT THE END, IT